la mairesse de longueuil a débuté sa
journée en questionnant les dirigeants
de son service de police les enquêteurs
n'ont toujours pas dresser de portrait
robot de l'agresseur du viol présumé de
carole thomas survenue il ya trois mois
deux jours avant le meurtre de joe nick
delcourt dans le même secteur
en toute franchise j'étais un peu
inquiète
quand j'ai vu la réaction de notre
service de police et je leur ai dit dès
la seconde où j'ai vu votre reportage en
leur disant on ne peut pas faire ça et
déjà j'ai demandé à ce que justement on
puisse apporter des correctifs
nous avons appris que la trousse
médico-légal de carole thomas qui peut
contenir des éléments de preuve comme du
sperme des cheveux et des ongles n'a été
envoyée au laboratoire de police
scientifique que le 17 janvier près de
trois mois après le dépôt de la plainte
jamais cela cet ancien enquêteur ne
comprends absolument pas que l'on puisse
oublier de faire analyser des éléments
de preuve aussi important sur l'identité
d'un présumé violeur je perçois
dictionnaire persuadé qu'un délai de
trop est ce que c'est une erreur grave
mais ça peut compromettre le déroulement
de l'anc a aidé aux proxénètes
catastrophique mais ça peut compromettre
le déroulement de l'enquêté
parce que des éléments de preuve là
dedans qui vont servait soit identifié
de suspect par l'entremise de l'adn la
police de longueuil admis du bout des
lèvres que la procédure habituelle
denquête en cas d'agression sexuelle ne
peut être pas été respecté autant note
des doléances de madame thomas et si on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya eu des erreurs qui a
eu
un délai quelconque on est pas capable
d'expliquer assurez vous que nous allons
prendre les mesures correctives pour
pour mieux servir la population au
téléphone le chef de la police de
longueuil denis desroches nous a dit
avoir commandé une enquête interne sur
la gestion du dossier de carole thomas
il admet qu'il est très inhabituel
d'attendre trois mois pour faire
analyser une trousse médico légal il a
demandé que désormais cela se fasse
systématiquement dans les jours qui
suivent le crime
et s'ils se fit langlois radio canada
montréal